قبل ايام زلزال تركيا وتحديدا قبل ثلاثه
ايام توقع باحث هولندي حدوث وقوعه وذكر
الدول التي ستتاثر بالزلزال كتب الخبير
الهولندي والباحث في شؤون الزلازل فرانك
هوجيتس كتب في تغريده ان زلزالا سيحدث
بقوه 7.5 درجات مئويه في منطقه جنوب وسط
تركيا والاردن وسوريا ولبنان وحذر في
تغريده اخرى من الارتدادات التي تتبع
الزلزال وشددا على ضروره مراقبه النشاط
الزلزال القوي الاضافي في وسط تركيا
والمناطق المجاوره قائلا انها عاده ما
تستمر لفتره من الوقت بعد وقوع زلزال كبير
[موسيقى]
على كل حال تغريده فرانكو كانت محطه
تساؤلات الكثيرين خاصه اهل الاختصاص في
الجغرافيا البيئه والزلازل حتى انه عاد
واكد تغريدته مفتخرا انه كان يعلم برغم من
ان هناك اجماعا على صعوبه التنبؤ بالزلزال
قبل حدوثه